this video is sponsored by software keep
get your Microsoft products at a
discounted price 42
Celsius that is cool
cool we got two of them the M2 Max and
the M2 Ultra and we're going to be doing
a lot of testing with these but in this
first video I really want to find out if
we can make this thing thermal throttle
so let's jump right into that now
getting right into it as you can see I
have a portable monitor set up to the
side right here with the tripod nice
little view for you guys and this is the
base model M2 Ultra Max studio for four
thousand dollars comes with 64 gigs of
RAM and the bend 60 core GPU so before
we get into the really intense
benchmarks and tests I do want to run a
simple geekbench 6 Benchmark now keep in
mind this is version six not five so the
scores should differ from what you're
used to and here we have our CPU scores
and you can see we're at 2600 single
core which is very similar to the M2 Max
right around the same within margin of
error but for the multi-core twenty
thousand seven eighty five which is the
best score out of any Mac beating the
previous M1 Ultra by about 18 so that's
for multi-core and beating the M2 Max
MacBook Pro by only around 44 and that's
because geekbench 6 uses a different
method where it has one large project
that all of the cores attack at once
instead of previously the task was
multiplied or duplicated for each core
which gave higher scores so only about
44 better and now let's quickly run the
60 core M2 Ultra GPU test holy moly 202
000 metal score that is absolutely
mind-blowing for geekbench six on this
M2 Ultra and that's only the 60 core G
2 model I'm excited to see how much the
fully unbinned version has because Max
is currently working on the Mac Pro with
the fully unbinned chip so subscribe
right now so you don't miss out on that
video but to put this score in context
202 000 if we look at the opencl charts
it's right up here with the best scores
out of any machine as you can see it's
almost as high as the 3080 TI and 3090
TI I'm curious to see what that unbin
chip does now the last test I want to do
before we start really pushing it and
trying to get it to Thermal throttle is
3D Marks Wildlife extreme unlimited
which will show us the difference in GPU
performance for gaming and I also have
MX power Gadget you can see it's peaking
at 83 oh my goodness it finished so
quickly 83 Watts right there on the GPU
and here we have our score
229.1 FPS for the m to ultra that's
actually 52 faster than the fully loaded
38 core M2 Max now that scaling is
actually very very good because this 60
core M2 Ultra has about 58 more cores
than the 38 core M2 Max so almost
perfect scaling just a little bit off
very very impressive and now let's get
into the big test we have cinebench R23
and we do have our sensors working
thanks to a beta version of TG fan Pro
which is awesome so we're going to start
off with a regular multi-core test to
kind of give us a baseline reading and
I'm also opening up MX power Gadget to
monitor the package power look at that
70 Watts right away from the CPU 71 and
it looks like we're running 3.26
gigahertz for the performance cores with
all of them fired up at once so it does
drop from 3.68 down to 3.26 when you use
all of them and here we have our score
941 and believe it or not the M2 Max in
the 16 inch MacBook Pro scored 13
888 so this is just over twice the
performance basically perfect scaling in
terms of the CPU apple good job on that
and now let's turn on the 10 minute
throttle test and Heat this thing up and
monitor what happens but before I get
into that if you like working with
documents spreadsheets or slideshows our
sponsor software keep is giving our
viewers 25 off on genuine Microsoft
software like Microsoft Office for Mac
they're fully legit since they're a
Microsoft certified partner with over a
hundred thousand five star reviews and
great customer service with 24 7 365
customer support so buy Microsoft Office
for Mac or any of their other software
today and save 25 off they're already
low prices by using the link below and
the coupon code
mtyt25 AS as we can see we have 3.26
gigahertz for the performance course
2.42 for the efficiency and so far it's
staying incredibly cool still only 61
degrees Celsius Max we are utilizing a
hundred percent of the CPU right now so
no issues there and wow this thing is
cooling it so well this is insane guys
it's been almost nine minutes and the
hottest core is only 83 degrees this is
mind-blowing It's been stuck at full 100
utilization basically the same clock
speeds they haven't changed this thing
is a beast it cools down so well
I can't even hear the fan it makes zero
sense that copper cooler is insane we
only have about one minute left so what
I want to do is plug in this thermal
camera and I want to look at the temps
look at that you can see the heat
towards the back of the Max studio let
me go around here 42 degrees Celsius was
the hottest I saw that is cooler than
the MacBooks get that is so impressive
and the fans
aren't even I can't even hear the fans
this is blowing my mind oh you can
actually see right here the fan is
basically at idle 84 degrees is the
highest temp oh 85.
literally 108 is the limit where it
starts throttling it's only at 85 and
now it's about to finish and there you
go we have our score and are you kidding
me
940. one point lower within margin of
error compared to our base score
basically zero thermal throttling or any
loss with a 10 minute stress test at 100
CPU usage basically you don't need the
Mac Pro this thing will cool the CPU
down by itself easily without the fans
even ramping up and now I want to try
and do the same thing but for the GPU
now I want to start off with some Final
Cut tests and I'm really curious to try
out the new encoders because apparently
with the M2 Ultra chip Apple finally
fixed the encoders because with the M1
Ultra you got the same encoding speed as
the M1 Max no improvement at all even
though it technically does have double
the encoders they just did not work and
it was a massive fail but now it seems
like they finally fixed it so let's try
it and now I want to start off by
exporting this five minute hevc project
this is the most common format that you
guys are going to be using right now
most people will be editing hevc so it
makes the most sense to run this first
so I've got my timer ready and let's hit
export as you can see right now the GPU
is only at 69 which makes it seem like
it's actually encoder limited which
means if you're doing this type of work
upgrading to the 76 core GPU will do
nothing for you exporting this type of
footage because it's limited by the
encoders and there you go 47 seconds to
export five minutes of hevc footage that
beats the fastest export scores that we
got on the M2 Max MacBook Pro and the M1
Ultra Max studio now we got 47 on this
M2 Ultra Max studio now that test of
course didn't do anything for throttling
because the GPU was not maxed out so
we've got to find something a little
different and now since that didn't
really ramp up the GPU to a hundred
percent we're gonna do the craziest test
ever our 8K Canon raw to 4K export which
you guys gave us crap for before for
running on a MacBook Air the M2 which
totally destroyed it made it throttle
this is the ultimate test so let's run
it on the M2 ultramax studio right away
we could see that the GPU is heading up
there towards 100 89 CPU is also being
used so it's attacking both of them at
the same time look at that we're about
32 percent done as you can see the temps
are ramping up slowly the gpus at just
under 90 usage 53 for the CPU and
surprisingly it's just not hitting it
for some reason the temps are still
staying cool about 70 degrees for the
CPU average of 53 for the GPU it seems
like something else is throttling it and
not allowing it to run at full
performance it's just about to finish
the CPU it's still only 82 degrees 62
degrees average on the GPU it's still
not enough to throttle the M2 Ultra and
the fans aren't even on as you can see
right here basically idle it just
finished 5 minutes and 14 seconds but
surprisingly it's only a little bit
faster than the 64 core M1 Ultra which
is 534 there was something else
throttling the system because it was not
Thermo throttling so something else in
there so basically none of that was
working nothing could heat up the system
and use both 100 CPU and GPU at the same
time so let's do this we have Lightroom
classic
542 megapixel photos opened at once
let's export these right over here and
I'm going to turn on a timer alright as
you can see finally 99 GPU 99 CPU it
kind of hovers back between 90 to 100
sometimes it dips a little on the CPU
side but now we're really using a lot of
power right here the temps are already
heating up quickly we're at about 75
degrees for the hottest CPU core 55 for
the GPU guys this is just shocking I
don't know how it's dissipating the heat
so well because the fans are still
idling and the temps only looking at 82
degrees Celsius for the hottest CPU core
it's just doing fine it makes no sense
how is this possible all right it just
finished three minutes and 14 seconds
for 500 photos we usually don't do that
much we usually do 50 that is absolutely
mind-blowing and the whole time the
hottest core that I got was 86 degrees
still nowhere near 108 that you need to
actually really thermal throttle this
thing and that was practically almost
100 CPU and GPU at the same time this
thing is blowing my mind and just to put
that score 3 minutes and 14 seconds into
perspective our last fifteen thousand
dollar Mac Pro with the 12 core Zeon and
Vega 2 GPU took over 12 minutes to
export these 500 photos but with all
that said the conclusion of this video
is that I can't get this thing to
throttle everything I could think of I
threw at it and it did not work only
went up to 85 nowhere near 108 this
thing is a beast you don't need the Mac
Pro cooler because that's definitely
Overkill because this thing's already
Overkill the
and stated Idle No matter what even in
that last test almost maxing out the CPU
and GPU at the same time and I think
even this 76 core version will have no
thermal throttling whatsoever this thing
is an absolute Beast so hopefully you
enjoyed this video if you did comment
down below and subscribe for more videos
coming up like this one very soon thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next one
foreign